five days after President Trump said he
hopes the country will reopen again by
Easter the president changed course and
announced an extension of federal
lockdown guidelines through the end of
April at least we will examine the catch
22 of kovat 19 then the World Health
Organization continues to bungle
coronavirus but never fails to parrot
Chinese Communist Party propaganda we
will take a look at the whu-oh
and why it needs to go and finally New
York Mayor Bill DeBlasio threatens to
shut down churches and synagogues
permanently if they have the audacity to
hold services during the pandemic all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you know what a catch-22 is a catch-22
is a situation where you are damned if
you do and you're damned if you don't
comes from the very famous novel
catch-22 and specifically what it refers
to is a military bureaucratic guideline
or loophole or problem which is that if
you don't if you get drafted you don't
want to go to the war you don't wanna
have to go fight you can claim insanity
and that will get you out of fighting
but the trouble is if you claim insanity
so that you don't want to go fight then
that's actually proof that you're sane
because nobody wants to go fight in the
war so therefore you can't play it
insanity and therefore you have to go
fight your it's a catch-22 you you
either either way you're stuck that is
the situation that the media have put
Trump in when it comes to coronavirus it
is the worst position that they have
backed him into during his entire
presidency
what is the catch-22 here the catch-22
is if President Trump wants to win in
2020 then he has to restart the economy
because right now we're getting to the
point where we're going to have millions
and millions of people unemployed you
could have 20% unemployment rate you
could have just absolute misery around
the country nobody gets elected with
those kinds of numbers but if President
Trump restarts the economy then he's
definitely not going to get reelected
because the the left generally but the
media specifically will blame him for
every single death every nut forget
death every sniffle that happens as a
result of coronavirus even if those
numbers of infection hospitalization and
mortality are are dramatically lower
than they predicted even if those
numbers are not even particularly
uncommon when it comes to diseases and
and viruses and flu season and the like
doesn't matter they'll blame him for
every single one so if he if he doesn't
restart the economy he can't get
reelected but if he does restart the
economy he can't get reelected at least
in all likelihood at least is as far as
the media is trying to push it so he's
damned if he does and he's damned if he
doesn't that is why he's holding these
daily press conferences okay
he's trying to instill confidence that
he's doing the best job that it is
possible to do even if the strategy
keeps changing course don't forget what
I think it was five days ago we were
told that we're gonna try to reopen the
country by Easter then yesterday we're
told we're gonna extend federal
guidelines to April 30th and in some
places those those guidelines and
lockdowns might be extended even further
places like New York which is now at the
center of coronavirus or Louisiana now
which is blowing up or other places too
so the strategy in some ways is changing
day by day initially it's not a big deal
then it's a much bigger deal then it
wasn't as big a deal now it's sort of a
big deal again but it doesn't matter
either strategy the media is gonna pin
him pin him for it they're gonna they're
gonna knock him on it so the key here is
to just get in front of it all the time
be making the case to the American
people that regardless of what strategy
you prefer he's taking control he's he's
doing a very good job so that's the big
coronavirus update from the press
conference yesterday the shutdowns are
going to continue through at least the
end of April remember initially the
Trump in the federal government said 15
days to slow the virus and in 15 days
we'll reassess well
15 days are up it's March 30th
the 15 days are up now we're told we've
got another month of 30 days 31 days to
slow the virus President Trump made the
announcement reluctantly but clearly
yesterday the peak the highest point of
death rates who remember this is likely
to hit in two weeks nothing would be
worse than declaring victory before the
victory is won that would be the
greatest loss of all therefore the next
two weeks and during this period it's
very important that every one strongly
follow the guidelines have to follow the
guidelines that our great vice president
holds up a lot he's holding that up a
lot he believes in it so strongly the
better you do the faster this whole
nightmare
and therefore we will be extending our
guidelines to April 30th to slow the
spread you can hear the reluctance in
his voice he's dragging on it it's like
he's trying to look for a way out even
as he's saying it well though look we
don't want to declare victory before the
thing is defeated because that would be
terrible right is that you're doing a
good job at containing the virus you're
doing a great job at testing actually
the reason that it now looks like the
United States has so many cases is is
just because we're testing we're testing
more than anybody else and because
China's lying in the w-h-o the World
Health Organization are covering for
them which we will get to in just a
little bit but the United States doing a
very good job now on this virus so
President Trump is saying well you don't
want it to like it's spiking and then we
do a really good job of containing it
and then we give up on that good job
when spikes again and that that will
look bad for him he wants to defeat it
once and for all but he's clearly
reluctant to do this that's why he's
contradicting his hope and aspiration
from just a week ago we're less than a
week ago he knows not only have the
media put Trump in an impossible
situation Trump knows that the media
have put him in an impossible situation
okay
fortunately though as crafty as the
media are president Trump is pretty
clever when it comes to outfoxing the
media you that might be his superpower
that's probably the skill that he is
best honed over all of these years and
so he has a new strategy for how to
outfox them regardless of where they
back him into regardless of what his
overall coronavirus strategy is we'll
get to that in one second first I've got
to thank our friends over at beard
supply you know one thing I'm noticing
about the quarantine and the shutdown is
guys are growing out their beards and
one thing that I'm noticing probably
you're noticing too if you're trying to
grow one out it's not as easy as it
looks okay
beard supply makes it so easy because
beards they can dry out they can get
itchy they can look very dumb beard
supply kelp helps keep your beard
healthy itch free soft and smelling
great and more than 10,000 beards agree
beard supply products are the best
out there each beard supply beard oil is
handcrafted what from 100% natural
ingredients with no synthetics no
mass-market essentials no sulfates no
paraphernalia and I grow a really good
beard except for like right there and it
doesn't look that great but now I really
want to try thanks to beard supply for a
short time beard supply is offering my
listeners 25% off just go to beard
supply.com use the promo code Knolls
canada bul es that is beard supply.com
using promo code knowles so the media
put Trump in this terrible position
Trump has a new overall yes he has a new
like top line strategy here even if the
actual particular strategy on the virus
changes we're going to keep the
quarantine s we're going to not keep the
quarantine we're gonna shut down we're
gonna reopen this top line media
strategy is that President Trump is
going to harp on the media's own
alarmist numbers what factors are you
taking into consideration what can the
American people expect and is it
possible that these April 30th
guidelines could be extended well we
hope not
but we think it's going to you know we
have aspirational thoughts we would have
loved to have been a little bit sooner
but we have to do it right we could have
done it we could have done it on Easter
but there was a good chance that if it's
coming down or if it's still going up
maybe it's going to be coming down by
that but we just felt it was too soon we
can't take a chance you know again
because of what we've done and because
of with the fact that we've stopped the
flow from China so early because the
question is from a lot of my friends why
don't we just wing it why didn't we just
wing it and I kept asking and we did
models now finally we got these models
in and you hear about the 2.2 million
people would have died I don't mean we
would have had two point two million
cases these are 2.2 million people would
have died 2.2 million people listen to
how many times he repeats that number
two point two million two
point two million people where's that
number coming from that was the number
that was touted by the media from the
very beginning that if the corona virus
spreads then we're gonna get 2.2 million
people dead in America did you believe
that number I was always a little
skeptical of that number but that was
the number that we were told by the
mainstream media by the experts right
you saw the number from Imperial College
in the UK that was that one study that
everybody said this is the study about
coronavirus turns out looks like there
were a lot of pretty serious flaws in
that study it looks like that number
might have been high so then you ask
yourself wait a second why is Trump of
all people trying to tout this very high
alarmist number that the mainstream
media touted from the beginning which
put him in this bad position in the
first place he's using the number
against the media because the press told
us 2.2 million puts Trump in a bad
position if he does nothing every death
proves he's heartless and a killer then
if he shuts down the world economy he
still looks terrible so what Trump needs
to do is take this seriously while still
giving himself room to reopen and the
key to that is managing expectations the
way to do that is to use the presses 2.2
million number against them right
because what the press wants to do now
is say that 20,000 30,000 40,000 50,000
deaths is totally unexpected
unprecedented impossible to believe
Trump has bungled this he's got blood on
his hands no of course we know that
37,000 people die each year of the flu
or more sometimes we know that 38,000
people die in car accidents every year
right we know that these numpy poleng
I think the statistic was a person dies
every 37 seconds from heart disease so
when you it's kind of morbid you don't
want to focus on these things a lot but
people die maybe seven seventy five
hundred people die a day I think in the
United States people die people are born
we don't like to focus on people dying
because it's sad and it makes us
contemplate our own mortality well I
don't want to have to do that
but because we ignore death so much then
when when numbers come up people are
shocked people are shocked to hear that
tens of thousands of people every single
year die from the flu because we don't
talk about it and the press is trying to
use that to their advantage to say well
if 50,000 people die from coronavirus
this is absolutely shocking and
unprecedented it's not it would be
terribly terribly sad 100,000 people
would be terribly terribly sad but it's
not shocking or unprecedented when we
were just told that 2.2 million people
were gonna die certainly a hundred
thousand is a lot better than 2.2
million or 200,000 for that matter would
be better than 2.2 million so President
Trump is trying to not let the press get
away with this they tout the alarmist
number and then they go down an order of
magnitude or more than an order of
magnitude and try to say that that's
just as bad Trump is going to hammer
this number home now to remind people
that even 100,000 deaths or more is
actually still a great victory in the
face of this horrible Chinese pandemic
that threatened to kill so many more
people so that's the number he's got to
keep hammering home and I think he's
gonna make the press sorry that they
were touting that alarmist that that
very likely alarmist figure again I
don't know but judging by the evidence
that has come out since that Imperial
College study it would certainly seem
that 2.2 million is a very high number
then President Trump wouldn't let the
press get away with another key little
talking point that they would try to get
away with which is the unemployment
checks you know the part of the stimulus
bill the bailout bill the relief bill
call it whatever you want part of that
bill was to allow Americans to get more
in the way of unemployment benefits
trouble is the federal government is not
administering them so ultimately Trump
is not responsible for how that's
implemented the states are going to
implement the unemployment relief and if
the states mess it up Trump is going to
get the blame so he's not gonna let the
press get away with that rely either
under this plan the average worker who
has lost his or her job will receive
100% of their salary for up to four full
months
the bill provides for these unemployment
checks to be delivered through the
existing state unemployment systems not
us state and I was opposed to this
method because many of the states have
very antiquated computer systems that
are 45 years old and they're not
prepared to handle this kind of
distribution this kind of money coming
in so quickly they're not set up for
that and I didn't want to do it but our
opponents wanted it so we did it and if
they don't get their money fast I'm
going to ask that we convene the federal
government that we come back to Congress
and we'll do something where we take
care of it because we can take care of
it very easily and quickly and I said
that but a lot of these systems are so
old and so antiquated at the state level
that they're going to have the money
they're going to get the money very
quickly but they're not going to be able
to distribute it so remember what I said
and we will if we have to call Congress
back or find some other way of delivery
of the money
don't blame me we didn't want it if they
screw it up it's not my fault
some people are knocking Trump here
because it looks like he's making
excuses that's not what's going on I
mean maybe he is making excuses if it
doesn't work out but really if the state
unemployment stuff doesn't work at that
isn't his fault what we're really seeing
here is that Trump is the most
transparent president in American
history and many people don't like that
actually the big attack on Trump for his
whole presidency is that he's too
transparent he's saying too much of what
he thinks he's tweeting out too much of
what comes into his mind he's talking
too much to people I mean look he's
holding his own daily press conferences
I bet you if if you if I said close your
eyes right now picture Stephanie Grisham
the White House press secretary I bet
you couldn't do that we used to know
what the press secretary looked like we
used to know what Sarah Sanders looked
like or Josh earnest or or all these
guys who were press secretaries now we
don't be as Trump is doing his own press
conferences because he's so transparent
Trump is like if you're a school child
if you're a student he's showing his
work he's always showing you his work
he's always showing you how we
from this place to that and why he
doesn't quite like this but it's okay
because we had to do this to get here
and so he's bringing you in on the whole
journey this is the only way he gets out
of this he's in the impossible situation
he's in the co vid 22 right the only
chance he has of getting out is showing
you his work so he can say here look
I've done everything I can if the states
screw me on the unemployment relief you
can't blame me for that I'm telling you
I'm planting in your mind right now
that's not what's going on I know that a
hundred thousand deaths would be
absolutely terrible but what all the
experts in the media were saying was 2.2
million deaths so it's very clear that
even a hundred thousand deaths shows
that we've done a remarkably good job
he's just showing his work the whole
time it's the only way he's not gonna
get totally blamed for this thing and
even that might not be enough so the
journalists are giving him absolutely no
leeway here there they don't want to
give him any breathing room so a
reporter brings up this point the Trump
has HAARP done that I have HAARP done
that a lot of other people have parked
on which is that the choice here is not
between save lives and make money oh my
you're willing to sacrifice lives on the
altar of money you monster you animal no
that's not the choice at all the I mean
what is the economy the economy is just
us right the economy is just people
doing things so there are always
trade-offs here so let's say you shut
down the entire economy maybe you save a
life or two but maybe one or two people
kills them she'll kill themselves
because that's what happens during
economic turn downs and so this report
Trump has made that points very good
point the reporter asks him excuse me
mr. president you've made that point
what scientific experts are you citing
to make that point again trying to back
Trump into this corner and take away his
political power because we've empowered
these scientific dictators in our
culture of technocracy and expertise
Trump totally flips it around on the
reporter you've also said that at one
point that you thought more people might
die from the economic tragedies and the
economic problems in
America due to the corona virus outbreak
what health officials are telling you
that and doctor foul she could you speak
to that the idea that there might be
mental health and suicide related to
this with that outpace at some point the
virus is impact on this society excuse
me um could we what experts what experts
are we talking about here what a dumb
question but this dumb question
highlights the worst instincts of the
left in this pandemic and that instinct
is to appoint Public Health dictators to
make our political decisions for us um
excuse me
duly elected president and leader of the
free world what does dr. fowey say who
cares what doctor foul she says I'm like
doctor foul she's doing a fine job but
doctor foul she is not the president
doctor foul she is not ultimately
responsible for making these decisions
and neither are you journalists because
I noticed by the way the journalists
only ever want to hear from the public
health officials who back up their own
preconceived notions
they never bring on the two scientists
from Stanford who said maybe we're
overreacting
they never bring on the 2013 Nobel
laureate who said we're all going to be
fine stop the alarmism
they never bring on the authors of the
oxford university study which undercuts
the study from Imperial College and
which says the mortality rate might be
significantly lower from coronavirus
they don't do that but what they want
they want to pretend that politics is
not politics that we're not just
persuading each other and trying to get
along with these questionable questions
that we're all grappling with they want
to pretend like like Karl Marx did that
politics is actually just a scientific
enterprise that there's a clear
scientific rule and if you just appoint
the right expert they can be the
dictator for ever and while I'll have a
perfect life so very dumb question
president Trump totally shuts her down
as dr. Faust you two come up but has
come and says you're gonna have massive
depression meaning mental depression you
can have depression and the economy also
but you're gonna have mental depression
for people you're gonna have large
numbers of suicides take a look at what
happens in a really horrible recession
or worse so you're going to have
tremendous suicides but you know what
you're gonna have more than anything
else
drug addiction you will see drugs being
used like
nobody's ever used them before and
people are gonna be dying all over the
place for from drug addiction because
you would have people that had a
wonderful job at a restaurant or even
owned a restaurant I spoke to great
people today that have done a great job
and one day that at the top of their
business their celebrity chefs they've
got the most successful restaurants and
in one day they have nothing they've
gotten wiped out one day from our enemy
this invisible horrible scourge of
course the left is falling into the same
trap that the public health experts are
they're being myopic say hey well what
scientific studies can you point to to
show that people get depressed when they
lose their job in the economy tanks I
don't know how about common sense how
about our own eyes how about all of the
experience of history you don't need a
scientific paper for that dummy use your
brain and Trump's oh man his response
here was so important because could you
imagine if this reporter whoever it was
asks Trump excuse me can you have doctor
foul Qi just talked about like whether
you're an idiot and a liar or not and
imagine from said okay sure doctor foul
Qi please tell her please o exalted foul
Qi please tell her that I'm a good
president and that I'm allowed to still
be president give me a break
if he had turned over the microphone at
that question to dr. Burks or doctor
foul Qi we wouldn't have a president
because we just we did because even
though right here even the Conservatives
even the duly elected president would
buy into the left's premise that
actually were just governed by a bunch
of appointed health experts but we're
not we're governed by the guy that we
elected why are the ratings so good the
ratings are through the roof from got in
trouble for talking about how high his
ratings are it's got like the best
ratings on TV three reasons here one
president Trump and the doctors and foul
Qi and Burks and the other experts and
the Surgeon General and everybody else
are giving people good information and
there's a lot of bad information out
there about this virus people who are
giving blazing hot takes that we're all
going to die or it's not a big problem
at all very little
the way of nuance very little in the way
of precise information so they're giving
people good information that's
up-to-date to trump and the doctors are
not scaring people to death
very important and three is my favorite
part
Trump is constantly dunking on the
people in the media who are scaring
people to death and who are spreading
false information so the best example
yesterday this was egregious even by CNN
standards CNN opens up a question with a
false premise about Trump the premise
was that Trump says that he needs the
governor's to show him gratitude
personally for what he's doing and then
President Trump calls out the reporter
about this and says I wasn't just
talking about me personally the reporter
then admits that the premise was a lie
and then the CNN reporter carries on
with the initial dishonest premise you
were talking about governors of
different states and you said I want
them to be appreciative you also said if
they don't treat you right I didn't I
don't call these are direct quotes sir
excuse me ready ready ready take a look
at what I said I want them to be
appreciative of me okay and then you cut
it off because it's fake those UN of
your administration please let me just
finish you just said it again and you
know the answers a lie you know your
statement and your response and your
answer is a lie because here's the story
you ready I said I want you to be
appreciative of me and then you go on
and then I go on and you cut it off but
it says you're not appreciative I don't
want them to say things that aren't true
I want them to be appreciative we've
done a great job and I'm not talking
about me I'm talking about Mike Pence
the task force I'm talking about that
you know the Army Corps of Engineers
thank you thank you thank you yeah and
how long did it take that CNN reporter
to get to it mr. president you said
people have to be really grateful to you
and show you appreciation or else you're
probably gonna withhold money or
something from them yes that's not what
I said
mr. president I could read you verbatim
what you said because it's not what I
said
I didn't say it was just about me mr.
president it's your own words here I'll
read it verbatim it's not about me and
Trump goes yeah thank you right thanks
for reading it
even that that national humiliation will
not derail the CNN reporter journalist
from his dishonest narrative this is
what they're going to do and by the way
it doesn't matter how much the media
undercut their own credibility here
why because even if people don't trust
the media the media still have a lot of
power to gin up hysteria okay that's not
even hypothetical we saw just this
weekend what the press will do to Trump
if he just immediately reopens
everything we saw it in their treatment
of Jerry Falwell at Liberty University
we'll get to that in a second we'll get
to what's rotten at the core of the
World Health Organization you know
throughout this whole pandemic people
have referred to the w-h-o the World
Health Organization is the leading
authority they're not an authority
they're a bunch of hacks they're in the
pocket of the Chinese Communist
government and we should stop funding
them we'll get to why because no one's
talking about that in just a moment
first I've got to thank our friends over
at oh you I've got to thank you thank
you so much for watching and listening
especially in your quarantine if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content called all-access live then
you've got to head on over to daily wire
comm and check it out we're gonna
continue this all of this week at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific I guess it's
technically a show but it's not really a
show pretty much we just turn a camera
on and we are hanging out for an hour I
know that we're all like going getting
cabin fever and going crazy in our
quarantine so this show is intended for
all access members but in time of
isolation we've opened it up to all of
our members not just the All Access Ones
so please let us know what you think of
it if you're around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. Pacific
tonight join us on the all-access live
show over at Daley wire.com head on over
daily wire comm slash subscribe you know
you will get one of the things you get
with that is the leftist ears tumblr and
I've never missed this tumblr more
because when I am at the studio we've
made a rule here to not use any washable
dishes or silverware or even the
beautiful leftist years tumblr just
because we don't we don't want to have
the PAS cleaning it and spread germs so
I've got to use this
I've got to use a a disposable coffee
cup absolutely awful I mean you can't
even if you put leftist tears in here it
would just dissolve the bottom and it
would just pour right out you need the
leftist tears Templar get your own and
then you won't need to worry about
spreading germs because it'll just be
your own tumblr daily Wired icon will be
right back with a lot more
it's not a hypothetical question about
what the media will do to Trump if he
just reopened suddenly they did it to
Jerry Falwell over the weekend and it
was fake news so Jerry Falwell decides
that you know the original federal
guidelines 15 days to slow the spread
that's fine we're gonna do that but
we're not gonna have 15 months to slow
the spread okay we got to reopen at some
point and he decided to reopen Liberty
University you know
mainstream media they don't like this
they don't like when you stop listening
to them and when you leave your
apartment and when you don't just
blindly follow whatever they say even if
it's based on the faulty imperial
college study New York Times Liberty
University brings back its students and
coronavirus - oh gosh you did there must
be grown of iris must be sweeping the
university must be hundreds of students
with it right the piece goes on the
decision by the school's president Jerry
Falwell Jr to partly reopen his
evangelical University enraged residents
of Lynchburg Virginia residents of
Lynchburg Virginia here being a stand-in
for New York Times editorial board
members but then here's the key line
they say then students started getting
sick so the rumor started by the
mainstream media is that you had 12
students immediately getting coronavirus
at Liberty University that's pretty bad
right pretty bad except it's not true
Jerry Falwell immediately came out and
refuted this he said we don't have a
dozen students with coronavirus running
around our campus we had four students
who decided to isolate because they came
from hotspots maybe they started the
sniffle or something like that but
haven't tested positive for it we had
one student who doesn't even live on
campus and is at home and so it's not
even like our decision would affect him
who seems to have coronavirus we had
some people who knew a guy who knew a
guy who was infected their self
quarantine out of an abundance of
caution but the story that the New York
Times is running but now Quran
is running rampant through Liberty
University just not true doesn't matter
if you ask people hey what happened when
Liberty University reopened you know the
story they're gonna they're gonna say
all the kids get coronavirus that's why
we can't reopen anything that's why
we've got to stay in our apartments
forever it is it isn't true at least
there's no evidence that it's true yet I
guess it could ultimately turn out to be
true I mean we know how viruses spread
we know that a lot of us are gonna get
this virus at some point but it doesn't
seem to be true now I mean even the idea
of flattening the curve right flattening
the curve doesn't reduce the number of
people who are infected it just spreads
out the number of people who will be
infected by this the idea being that if
the curve gets too high then you're
gonna overwhelm the hospital systems and
that's gonna result in more people dying
because you know they won't let's say
someone gets into a car accident that
all the hospital beds are gonna be taken
up with coronavirus patients so they're
not going to be treated there's gonna be
all this fallout too but that's how the
media narrative has shifted it went from
2.2 million people are gonna die to some
hospitals are gonna be overrun
doesn't matter it's the same narrative
and and they're they're trying to tell
you every time we test they say we need
more tests but then the moment you get
more tests then obviously you get more
diagnosis and when you get more
diagnosis they say we're losing the
battle against coronavirus so many a
little ko vid 22s here that are tripping
up conservatives who are trying to do a
good job and fight this virus that's
that's what Trump is up against he knows
that those are gonna be the headlines
which is why he's trying to zigzag his
strategy a little bit here all the while
showing you the work all the while
showing you the impossible situation
that he has been put in and guess what
most people approve of what he's doing
we showed you poll last week Gallup
polling showed most people approve other
polls have shown it now we have one from
the Washington Post and ABC News two
outlets that don't particularly care for
Donald Trump this new poll from them
asked the question do you approve or
disapprove of the way Donald Trump is
handling his job as president so this is
overall approval rating 48% of
respondents said they approve 46% said
they disapprove so he's still under 50
here but more approved than disapprove
34% of
strongly 15% improved somewhat 35%
disapproves strongly 11% disapproved
somewhat 6% have no opinion by the way
who are those people who has no opinion
about Donald Trump you've got to be
locked in a bunker away somewhere if you
don't then the poll gets to do you
approve or disapprove of the way Trump
is handling the corona virus outbreak 51
percent of respondents approve 45% do
not approve so now he is totally above
water here he's even above the 50% mark
most people even people who don't like
the job he's doing his president like
the job he's doing on coronavirus and in
that environment even Joe Biden the
presumptive Democratic nominee the guy
who if he can make it I guess is gonna
run against Donald Trump in November
even he is giving President Trump some
credit on the corona virus when Chuck
Todd left wing hack asks Biden if Trump
has blood on his hands for his handling
of coronavirus Biden much wiser looking
at those poll numbers says whoa Chuck
what are you talking about calm down
there you know your campaign put out
you're in a critique of President Trump
and says if he doesn't do these things
you know he could he could cost lives do
you think there's already do you think
there is blood on the president's hands
considering the slow response or is that
too too hard for the criticism I think
that's a little too harsh I think what's
happening is that failure to as I
watched a prelim to your show where
someone said that may made the fray use
the phrase that the president just
thinks out loud he should stop thinking
out loud and start thinking deeply he
should start listening to the scientists
before he speaks he should listen to the
health experts okay first of all
President Trump clearly is listening to
the health experts he's holding daily
press conferences with two of the most
prominent public health experts in the
entire country he's letting them speak
and he's regularly deferring to them and
on every question but on a great many
questions that's why foul Chi and Burks
are now international celebrities second
Joe Biden criticizing anybody for
speaking before he thinks is the most
pot-kettle e-sword
situation I've heard of in weeks are I
probably not what Joe should be doing so
why is Joe giving Trump credit here he's
giving Trump credit because Joe Biden
was dead wrong on coronavirus and it to
use Chuck Todd's question if Joe Biden
had been permitted to follow the policy
that he wanted to follow he would have
blood on his hands because when Donald
Trump issued the travel ban from China
way way back at the end of January right
probably the single most important thing
he could have done to stop the spread
just look at Italy if you want to see
another example Joe Biden criticized him
for it said he wouldn't have done it
called him xenophobic so Biden knows
he's in a bad spot here he knows Trump
is popular on Wu flu
despite being backed into this catch-22
so Joe is gonna play this fairly neutral
you know Trump has managed to stay
popular during the coronavirus not
through any reasonable way there is no
reasonable way right there is no way to
kind of pick just one strategy and go
for it and that's how you would stay
popular that has been closed off to him
so he's managed to stay popular pretty
much through sheer force of will he's
managed to stay popular through daily
press briefings by the way the daily
press briefings coincide with when that
approval ratings started to go up again
and it's blunted the best attack that
Democrats have on him we've got to get
to why the World Health Organization is
a totally corrupt institution that does
not deserve our defense first let's try
to get to a couple questions from
listeners I see you're popping up from
SW after all the positive news for Andy
Cuomo older brother to Fredo
governor of New York any thoughts on him
being Biden's vice president or could
Andy even hop into the race this late I
don't think he'll be Biden's vice
president I think Biden needs a woman
ideally a black woman because he knows
that the Democrats were obsessed with
racial and sexual identity politics and
Joe Biden is an old white guy so even
though Andy Cuomo might have a lot of
energy he'd probably be a pretty strong
candidate I don't think he would be the
VP also Joe Biden doesn't need to win
New York he'll win New York he doesn't
need any help doing that rather
now could Andy Cuomo get into the race
this late look Joe Biden is in bad shape
okay he doesn't look good he's
forgetting his name he's forgetting his
boss's name he he doesn't seem to have
any energy we're in the midst of a
global pandemic that targets people who
were exactly in Joe Biden's demographic
there's a world in which he just doesn't
have the stamina to actually be the
nominee and in that case you'd get into
a pretty crazy convention maybe they'd
go with Bernie
maybe the Wicked Witch of the West
swoops in there and takes the nomination
at the last minute or maybe a young
up-and-coming he's not that young but he
is more energetic more youthful
candidate like Andy Cuomo who obviously
has designs on the presidency
maybe he swoops in at the last minute I
think there's a better shot that he
could pop in and try to make a play for
the big job then that he would be the VP
another question from a see Michael
fellow Sicilian here how do you feel
about what's happening to your ancestors
I'm talking about my friends back across
in the old country well it's kind of
interesting because generally in Italy
the southern part of Italy is considered
the poor part the less prestigious part
the less posh part and the north
specifically Milan fashion capital of
Italy and industrial capital of Italy
that's considered the nicer area and yet
what's what's being hit most yell on
Lombardi the north of Italy is being hit
much harder on coronavirus than those
backwards Sicilians where my ancestors
come from our shows you one of the
weaknesses of globalization because it
was lumber tea that decided to import a
ton of very low wage Chinese workers to
man their factories and when they didn't
cut all that off you saw an influx of
obviously this Chinese pandemic come in
specifically there the other thing that
it shows you is that America is a
different country from Italy okay we've
got a different population dr. Burks
made this point yesterday different
population a different demographic we
know our population is not as old our
population especially among the old
people do not smoke as much I mean
Italians to smoke cigarettes all the
time so respiratory diseases really
affect them it shows you the differences
in countries not just from the
globalization standpoint and how we got
the disease but how people are treating
it as well
speaking of globalization the WHL World
Health Organization is a mouthpiece for
the Chinese Communist Party take a look
at how this w-h-o hack refuses to answer
a question about Taiwan which is
independent from China but not totally
independent from China and China wants
to completely take it over he's asked a
question about Taiwan he pretends not
even to hear it the WTO considered
Taiwan's membership
hello I couldn't hear your question okay
yeah let me let me repeat the question
let's move to another one then okay hold
on you you didn't hear that and he says
this this is so spooky it shows you that
these weirdo bureaucrat mouthpieces for
communist dictators are they're so
cold-blooded man that's like ice running
through their veins just a completely
straight face not answering that not
answering that not answering that sorry
I didn't hear your question
okay I'll repeat it no that's okay let's
move on well how do you know you want to
move on to the next question if you
didn't hear the first question now this
journalist to her credit persists I'm
actually curious I'm talking about
Taiwan as well on Taiwan's case we
decided to give dr. L word another call
to follow up and I just want to see if
you can comment a bit on how Taiwan has
done so far in terms of containing the
virus well we've already talked about
China and you know when you look across
all the different areas of China they've
actually all done quite a good job so
with that I'd like to thank you very
much for inviting us to participate and
and good luck as you go forward with the
battle in Hong Kong yes thank you very
much so spooky isn't it thank you so
much thank you yes we've talked about
China which owns Taiwan Taiwan is just
part of China or paymasters no what do
you I'm not a marionette for the
communist government what are you blah
blah blah okay goodbye goodbye I talk to
you later really spooky stuff how and
why did this happen why why is the WH
ere the World Health Organization
mouthpiece for Communist China so it
looks like China knew about this virus
now as early as mid-october
initially we thought it was January that
December than November now it looks like
mid-october trying to cover it up it
punished whistleblowers it silenced
journalists who reported on it w-h-o
consistently praised the CCP the
Communist Party of China for its
transparency quote and leadership saying
its actions were
making us safer w-h-o experts didn't
even go to China until February 10th
China knew about this since mid-october
WH o did not want any part of it the
most aggressive campaign the WH o is
waged during this whole epidemic is to
stop people from calling this the
Chinese coronavirus you think what wait
why is the WH o telling me what language
to use they actually had this campaign
don't call it the Chinese coronavirus
don't call it the Wuhan virus parroting
the Chinese Communist line so who is the
who the WH o why is the WH o so bad WI
shows a division of the United Nations
which there tells you enough of about
them you know they're already tampers
our expectations why is it so bad the
Federalists had a good piece on this so
bad B as the head of it is a prop for
Chinese Communists Tedros HOD Hunnam
Gabry seus former job was in the Marxist
government of the Ethiopian People's
Revolutionary Democratic Front as the
Washington Post reported China worked
quote tirelessly behind the scenes to
install this guy as the head of the wh
Oh China has been working for years
behind the scenes to take over
international institutions to try to
ease their normalization there are
Chinese dictatorship a communist
dictatorship but they're trying to enter
the world as this kind of international
wonderful democratic country the China
already runs four of the UN's
specialized agencies no other country
controls more than one clear takeaway
here okay we give the w-h-o half billion
dollars a year we are by far the biggest
contributor to the w-h-o and yet the wh
o is a mouthpiece for China
we need to defund w-h-o until it's china
patsy leader is ousted we should cut off
their money I know there's this idea
that Trump is going to cut money from
the w-h-o the World Health Organization
that's gonna compromise public health
it won't they're useless they do nothing
they're worse than useless
they help communist thugs cover up the
worst pandemic we've seen in our
lifetimes get rid of them get rid of the
money asked the leader it's done enough
of them in the mean
we need to remain very skeptical of
anything they say before we go I've got
to get to Bill DeBlasio bill de blasio
now is telling people to stay in their
homes even when it comes to churches and
synagogues he says I want to say to all
those who are preparing the potential of
religious services this weekend if you
go to your synagogue if you go to your
church and attempt to hold services
after having been told so often not to
our enforcement agents we'll have no
choice but to shut down those services
but he didn't just say he would shut
them down for a week or so
he threatened to shut them down
permanently it's been instructed that if
they see worship surfaces going services
going on they will go to the officials
of that congregation to inform them they
need to stop the services and disperse
if that does not happen they will take
additional action up to the point of
fines and potentially closing the
building permanently closing it
permanently de Blasio is unabashedly
anti religious most evidence seems to
suggest he's an atheist he sort of
pushed back on the atheist thing but he
says he doesn't have a religion he
doesn't have a church he doesn't like it
he's a commie
so generally they're not particularly
traditionally religious people that's a
bridge too far to shut down the churches
permanently if de Blasio permanently
forced churches to close the most
measured and reasonable response would
be to riot now I say would be to riot
because Christians as a rule don't riot
Jews don't either it's so interesting
that in his line here about shutting
down these religious services he only
targets two religions he says if you go
to your synagogue if you go to your
church what's missing here notice any
any religious service that he left out
hmm I notice a particular religion of
peace that he refused to name here that
he refused to threaten he's only
threatening the Jews and the Christians
he's not threatening other religious
groups
the reason I suspect is that he's not
afraid of any reprisals from Christians
or Jews he thinks they're just gonna
take it and I don't know he clearly has
some particular antipathy toward
Christians and Jews that he doesn't have
towards say Muslims or Hindus or other
groups as well that is a step too far
this country if if it is founded on any
one thing in particular it is on the
ability to practice your religion so
what the pilgrims came over on the
Mayflower for we have no established
Church at the federal level all sorts of
different religions have thrived in
America were much more religious than
the rest of the Western world religion
really matters it is completely
gratuitous and unnecessary to threaten
to permanently shut down religious
institutions if the government were to
do that the government would be
illegitimate very extreme position
they're trying to put everybody in now
very tough for those of us on the
receiving end of it to react you got to
be careful not to allow yourself to be
back as they want us to be into an
impossible situation there are ways to
get out of this but you've got to be
very careful because at this point we're
not just talking about a public health
pandemic we're talking about a highly
politicized agenda that is being pushed
to advance political goals all right
that's our show I'm Michael Knowles's
the Michael Noel's show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Winooski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you